after the hustle and bustle of e3 let's
slow down to a crawl here
take a deep breath and take an even
closer look at breath of the wild sequel
between cross-referencing both trailers
my personal findings and people's
theories posted online
i have a bit more information about how
things will go down in the highly
anticipated sequel
this won't be a 100 full breakdown of
everything rather more focused on
interesting points that i haven't seen
too much talked about yet
we still do breath of the wild content
to this day so if you want to see more
from us let us know by liking this video
now let's take a closer look even though
there were only short snippets of the
ganondorf scene in this trailer compared
to the first trailer these small scenes
built more context and answers that
weren't so clear from the first trailer
alone
using reference points of when link's
arm gets affected by the new entity and
the malice
and when we see ganondorf's malice
filled eyes are active
we can partially piece together what's
happening at the beginning of breath of
the wild sequel
let's take a short look at my possible
version of what happened then slow it
back down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now let's take a closer look and
describe some key scenes the first one
of note is this scene here
where the finger moves by the way zelda
is acting calmly and the shots before
i'm very sure the seal hand is still on
ganondorf at this point
but the way this is portrayed it seems
ganondorf has some powers and is able to
slightly move
while sealed and or was triggered by the
arrival of link and zelda which is
understandable i mean this is possibly
the entirety of the triforce standing in
one room we're talking about here
at this point something happens and the
room starts to shake likely caused by
ganondorf
and the ground gives way causing zelda
to fall through while link goes to save
her the most important sequence happens
next
the seal hand catches link putting two
and two together this is now highly
likely that the steelhand released
ganondorf to try and save zelda and
link's fall
although now we know that it was only
half successful now that ganondorf is
free of the hand seal his eyes of malice
come to life
as seen in the next shot of him
seemingly summoning more malicious
malice from the second trailer
this is likely when link was attacked as
his right arm is still normal at this
time and all throughout the game
it seems like this arm is fused with a
ceiling arm so this arm fusing is
definitely the last thing that happens
at this point it's pretty clear what
happens next with the malice spreading
throughout hyrule castle lifting it
skyward
it's possible during or after this
castle raising sequence that link then
fuses with the entity
fairly likely to cure the malice that
damaged his right hand
since this undergarment definitely gives
off more zonaish vibes than his normal
blue undergarments in this scene
it's likely he woke up in the sky which
is often shown off with this type of
clothing
while this edit gives much more context
to the situation there are obviously
many elements missing so
hopefully if another trailer drops in
the future we can further build upon the
story
clearly something has happened between
link and the master sword as this is the
final shot in the small timeline that we
have of link having the master sword
with him
he has no gauntlet on his arm compared
to before possibly from the previous
mouse attack
so this must have happened after this
shot so at this point it is
possible he is unable to wield the sword
of evil's bane after being affected by
malice since the sword achieved and
since these shots are highly likely to
happen in this order of acquiring and
then settling in the new arm
it's inferred that link passed out and
may have lost his equipment against his
will
which is an obvious reset point as the
beginning of the game an interesting
point with this situation though is if
there's ever a problem with the master
sword or it is misplaced
it returns to the korok forest but in
this case as proven in the trailer the
deku tree is gone and even possibly dead
in the sequel
so maybe korok forest and subsequently
the sword pedestal could have problems
as well
the fate of the master sword is severely
unclear at this point
we just don't know how it will appear in
the future
while there are many obvious and subtle
knowledge to previous games such as
twilight princess
ocarina of time and skyward sword i
personally think that miyazaki
influences and themes and tones are too
large to ignore
in the original breath of the wild there
were already so many things that you
could pick out that shows miyazaki's
influences
but the astounding thing is that in just
two small trailers for the sequel
a game we know barely anything about
we've seen references for two of
miyazaki's films multiple times
princess mononoke and castle in the sky
from roots growing through floating land
masses filled with stone paths
to a pair of explorers going through
glowing caves and cursed tendrils
attacking the hero's arm
the nod to studio ghibli's work is still
undeniable
at this point it's pretty much confirmed
that the mysterious zonai or whatever
this racist name is has an integral part
in the upcoming sequel
the references to patterns and designs
are really hard to miss the zonai are an
ancient warlike tribe from the far on
region
an architecture from their ruins in the
far-on region are sparsely seen
throughout hyrule
examples such as the dragon's breath
shield carvings on the walls
and this pillar design definitely give
off zonai's involvement
dragons also seem to have some general
importance as the music played at the
end of the trailer
half of zelda's lullaby is played by an
erhu
[Music]
a chinese instrument that is also used
in the dragon's theme
this is telling because there are
already theories floating around the
dragon's portal and how that ties into
the world above
these scenes and locations may hold some
importance in the future
one thing that is confirmed after
staring at the shield for a while is
that this is not one piece of equipment
rather definitely an attachment to a
regular shield the shield link is
holding is definitely the wooden shield
but it is still unknown if you are able
to properly
block with this massive thing in front
of you another thing to think about is
if bullet time is returning
there certainly wasn't enough combat in
this teaser to get any concrete
information
but i'm wondering if the slowdown
mechanic is returning to the sequel at
all
this backflip didn't trigger any sort of
flurry rush although it could be a
sidestep dodgeable attack that they
dodged incorrectly to not trigger it or
this attack isn't flurry rushable at all
nintendo has shown this mechanic off in
previous breath of the wild original
trailers
so they may be reworking mechanics
behind the scenes or the studio is
simply not showing everything off in
these trailers
also an important note just by seeing
these islands in the sky are the
island's wall textures
they seem very unfriendly for climbing
with aggressive almost 45 degree walls
at some points and jagged edges with
almost no places to rest
it's possible that these sides are
mechanically designed just like shrine
walls
unclimbable and making you fall down if
you attempt to climb it
if that's true this empty gap where
roads end may require a special skill to
cross the gap of this size
you couldn't just jump and paraglide
across this if the walls are unclimbable
while it could be as simple as some
magic bridge that appears here i'm still
crossing my fingers for some sort of
grapple arm ability
which with this creature's similar
energy and seemingly extendable neck
design
could be a template for link's
extendable arm and this has been in
concept art before
i mean crazier concept art has come true
so who knows
and those were all the points that i had
that were worth bringing up of course
we're very excited for the next trailer
and the final release
so we'll be delving very deep into the
game when it comes out as mentioned
earlier we still do tips tricks and
breakdowns of the first breath of the
wild
so stick around for everything zelda and
keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
you